dank für die freilichtaufführung gesagt
hier ist wie die tanten spiel
digitalisierung muss man genauer sagen
was der unterschied zwischen
digitalisieren und die vitalität ist das
wirklich ein sehr wichtiger begriff ist
werde ich später noch sagen eigentlich
schon gesehen
bei mir sind kamera hier ist eigentlich
hier ist monitor dieser uhr wird
aufgezeigt und der live-stream über mein
bild im café lukas das werde jetzt
intern hat oder sonstigen möglichkeiten
hat kann da reingehen und kann sogar
auch mit ketten und kommunizieren kann
mir gleich kleine kommentare
reinschreiben wenn er das möchte
ich habe mich an mit meinem thema und
zwar möchte beginnt mit einem vor einem
zitat von georg friedrich wieder wickeln
der satz sie kennen alle wahrscheinlich
dieses zitat die eule minerva beginnt
erst mit der einbrechenden dämmerung
ihren flug also ungefähr jetzt in dieser
tageszeit eine bibliotheks nachts sein
könnte im alten philosophie beginnen zu
revidieren und nachzudenken über das was
eigentlich ist was damit gesagt es wird
jetzt so viel dass ihr sowie über erst
kommt wenn es eigentlich schon zu spät
ist also wenn da schon was passiert ist
ein referent ihren sieg über ich möchte
ein bisschen was hingegen setzte nämlich
digitale philosophie gegeben bereits
mittagszeit wenn die sonne noch scheint
also nicht ihres in der zeit nach
was meine ich damit nicht mal mit
folgendes die kleine philosophie was
auch immer sitzt zeigte gleich drauf
angehen die muss es machen die muss wie
es hier auch gesagt die philosophie als
lose wie ihre zeiten geht amgen erfassen
und das bedeutet wie mir scheint ihm das
mich ist nach sind das was ist schon
gewesen ist
seine philosophischen anstrengungen
unternimmt sondern gerade auch dann wenn
es philosophisch interessant ist und
wenn die sonne scheint oder was meint
ihr ist in diesem sollen auch scheinen
dann eigentlich eigentlich nichts
anderes als das das wir gerade überall
finden sich zuletzt auch gerade hier
nämlich die digitalisierung zunächst
einmal gibt es ein sehr interessantes
buch mit dem titel die 50 wichtigsten
themen der digitalisierung kann ich sehr
empfehlen daher dass alle möglichen
bereiche angesprochen die uns der
lebenswelt betrifft in robotik
nanotechnologie smarthome sexualität
heraus waren uns sofort und mit diesen
dingen müssen wir philosophin uns mit
unserem auch beschäftigen wie es scheint
und ich bin alles zu spät ist und es
kann halt immer so viel natürlich
verschiedenes bedeuten ich fange damit
an was sie in meinen augen nicht
bedeutet oder nicht bedeuten sollte
ich sollte meinen augen nicht bedeuten
zukunft spekulation hast was könnte das
sein und denken dass eine ganz verrückte
dinge auch entspannend ist nicht eine
philosophie digitale philosophie über
haben was ist auch nicht sein sollte da
ist in meinen augen ist science fiction
es geht auch so ein bisschen zu
spekulation oder das ist auch nicht sein
sollte in meinen augen ist trans oder
post humanismus also überlegung und wie
wir menschen zu besseren menschen werden
dazu neue menschen zu erwähnen oder
sogar zu etwas werden über mich ich
glaube dass der mensch immer mehr
schwein wird und dass die
anthropologischen dem über die seltenste
ich glaube nicht an über wenn ich aber
an oder kann man natürlich streiten also
diesem teil der spekulation science
fiction und transfer post journalismus
haben ein auge nicht mehr so viel als
digitaler entscheidung nichts zu tun
sondern digitale philosophie bedeuten
meinen augen philosophieren über das
digitale aber auch noch mehr
philosophiert ein paar selbst digital
ist dass selbst im digitalen medien
verstärken kind und was ja ganz
interessant ist ist er ist nole system
könnte man solche gedanken
die können wir nämlich als eine art
paradigma für das digitale fernsehen
nutzen da und ich kommen auch später
drauf gegend ist wie sie alle wissen
vernetzt denken funktioniert ganz
ähnlich wie diese digital phänomene die
wir so bei allen immer mehr erkennen
wäre neuronalen jetzt das sind ja nur
letztendlich simulation oder mit
nachbauten unseres denkens was gilt
unsere gern bedingt
und das sind auch noch ganz sind halt
sein scheint für digitale philosophie
ist die leute des raumes und der zeit
mal ganz radikal hinterfragen weil ich
glaube dass der modifikation unseres
raumes brauche zeit verständnisses der
neuen ordnung ist entscheidet ob wir die
digitalisieren oder genau die
digitalität ich verstehen können wir
müssen also frauen zeitung soll jetzt
aber meine zwei differenzen gegeben
nämlich zunächst differenzen analog und
digital
das ist die technische sergan analog wie
es alle wissen sind informationen die
kontinuierlich sind die sich unendlich
weiter differenzieren lassen und es
betrifft sowohl den mikrokosmos also zb
atome die ganz immer weiter zu teilen
als auch den makrokosmos sie kann immer
weiter ins universum hineinschauen
denken immer wieder
digital hingegen malt nichts ist ja dass
conti das geplante also dass alle
elemente aus denen wir dann wie 2001 in
uns allen räten rekonstruieren diese
differenz ist analog und digital ist
sicherlich interessant aber es ist ihre
technische zeit was jetzt in meinen
augen philosophisch wirklich interessant
ist die differenz zwischen
digitalisierung und digitalität sie
haben bestimmt in den griff schon mal
gehört dass ein bisschen modewort
geworden
das hat jetzt in der digitalität im
gegensatz zur digitalisierung auf sich
was ist also digitalität ich würde sagen
die qualität ist die reflexion haus die
digitale transformation als technisches
seid also was geht damit alles einher
wenn jetzt plötzlich alles digital wird
also alles gekannte in 09 einzeln oder
wie auch immer realisiert und nach
gebaut wird
damit ist zum beispiel die kulturelle
ästhetische psychologische logische
ontologische und auch die ist die
ethische dimension dieser digitalen
transformation gemeint die wir in so
vielen versuchen reflektieren kann und
auch soll und die entscheidende frage
die sich mir jetzt ist diejenige haben
wir mit der digitalität also mit der
reflexion und mit der völligen
lebensweltlichen einbindung der
zunehmend ein bild bindung digitaler
strukturen eine neue natur geschafft
nicht an der zeit natur die uns den
kulissen eine dritte natur das ist
wesentlich jetzt hier so ein bisschen
hervor bringen möchte und auch
verteidigen möchte meine ts ist die
digitalität gehört nicht zur alten natur
die kultur sei nicht so drin also eine
neue natur ist hier stehen ja was ist
jetzt schon ein zeichen kultur das
wissen sie alle das ist die und schon
den zweiten natur kultur die ebenso viel
bedeutet wie künstliches existieren wie
die tatsache dass uns kleidung anziehen
dass wir musizieren das ist jetzt anders
für unser zusammenleben und so weiter
und so fort was sie als objektiven geist
bezeichnen würde das kann uns alles dazu
zählen erster natur hingegen ist einfach
die natur die ruhe natur es ist gibt die
nichts künstliches an sich hat und jetzt
müssen wir zeigen wenn die qualität
wirklich eine dritte natur konstituiert
dass ich in ihren frauen ihren
phänomenen kausale strukturen aufzeigen
lassen die sich nicht mehr reduzieren
lassen
auf kulturelle phänomene wir müssen also
zeigt als jetzt wenn meine eigene
realität handelt
das ist die herausforderung wir das
nicht schaffen dann glauben wir müssen
wir sagen digitalität ist halt meine
form und zurzeit natur und kultur
besonders moderne aber es ist
kontinuierlich zu zeigen hat und wenn
wir die mir vertretene these weiter
belegen wollen dass ich um eine neues
würde herrn dann ist eine ganz bestimmte
phänomene aufzeigen aufweisen und zeigen
dass die causa möglich werden
wir müssen ihre eigene realität
herausgreifen und wir müssen kategorie
entwickeln die diese eigene realität der
dritten natur angemessen fassen und das
erreichen wir meinen augen
dadurch dass wir die dritte natur als
digitalität mit der zeit dazu unsere
bekannten kultur kontrastieren also
immer gegenüber stehen und wir dass ein
paar unterschiede was sind die dimension
der zeit natur ich habe damals sogar
aufgelistet also individualisierung
scheint mir ganz zentral zu sein sobald
kultur entsteht hochkultur immer er wird
als individuum plötzlich bedeuten also
wir als personen als unverwechselbare
einzigartige dinge die interaktivität
spielt eine große rolle wir versuchen
unser zusammenleben als individuen zu
ordnen durchgezählt sind durch vorgaben
zur normalität
wir kritisieren die entsprechen die für
gegenständliche von uns wir wollen nicht
als gegenstände in der kunst
wahrgenommen werden sondern wir wollen
als subjekt als personen die wie dem
wahrgenommen werden und wir können das
was gewesen ist als geschichte ansehen
als geschichte er innen und wieder
repräsentieren aber wir müssen das was
gewesen ist wieder mühsam aus dem
schleier aus dem sumpf der vergangenheit
heraus geführt den wir zum beispiel
archäologie oder andere kollegen
betreiben
und ich glaube dass die dritte natur der
digitalität zu diesen von mir jetzt
genannten punkte in der gewissen
kontrast situation steht und dann möchte
ich jetzt ein paar dimension der
digitalität nennen die glaube ich zur
zeit natur babys gerade geschrieben
haben andi worenz eröffnet unser
folgendes ich glaube dass die
digitalität durch verlegt so ganz
zentral gekennzeichnet ist damit eine
hier stellten eine form von
subjektivierung entindividualisierung zu
klären
mehr worten erscheint digitalität zur
objektivierung zu finden und zu
erträglichen und zu in die zeitlichen
und wenn was hat es damit genau auf sich
ich will jetzt also paar kategorie die
in meinen augen die digitalität wir sie
muss gut beschreiben und in der folge zu
bleiben von merck schulen und kulturen
möchte ich die digitalität als 2800 die
textur nennen als wir haben jetzt natur
kultur und den text vor textur können
sie schon ein bisschen denke es geht um
einen gewissen teil ist als erste
kategorien würde ich gerne den begriff
der objektivität prem
während in seiner subjektivität sind das
ganze zwar alle schlagwort für die
kultur ist gesellschaft unserer sofort
bei ninja objektivität jetzt im dritten
natur der textur dass wir als subjekte
plötzlich mit dem dingen in einer
beziehung treten und zwar dadurch dass
die dinge selbst mit uns kommunizieren
die gehen können mit uns im internet
vernetzt werden die
können selbst smart gegenstände seien
als smart objects damit kannst du helfen
verbunden werden das heißt wir wissen
wie unser kühlschrank analytics wir
treten mit dem gegen stellungen der eine
fiel mehrere beziehung als sie es sonst
tun wird jetzt selbst werden plötzlich
auch mit denselben kategorien wie die
gegenstände plötzlich erfassbar und das
scheint jetzt eine von interaktivität zu
führen
in weiteren kategorien die jetzt also
hier ganz schnell einfach meine haut
werden möchte ist ein bisschen
kompliziert jetzt habe ich jetzt meine
passion präsentismus und was hat es
damit auf sich
typisch märz wird es bloß und
präsentiert muss man das halt alles
gegenwärtig ist damit wirklich einige
nur folgendes sagen das internet
vergisst nichts also das scheint mir
eine ganz zentrale dimension der
digitalität ist sein wenn sie einmal
digital sich in die welt des internets
begeben haben dann sind sie prinzipiell
immer wieder
offenbach es gibt es irgendwo sie alle
homepages der vergangenen jahrzehnte
kann man schon sagen wir mit workshops
mit kurzen speicherung staaten wieder
aufrufen können das internet vergisst
nichts und das scheint mir unsere logik
von raum und zeit grundsätzlich im
gegensatz zu kultur zu verändern
ein weiterer grund der mir sehr sehr
entscheidendes der die externalisierung
der gedanke gdl internet alle
miteinander in beziehung stehen scheint
mir das internet selbst wert von gehirn
zu funktionieren in das wir alle mit
einbezogen werden
und wodurch die subjektivierung unsere
individualisierung immer mehr
zurücktritt
diese drei kategorien scheine ganz
zentral zu sein
für diese neue dimension wird
und jetzt hat man natürlich die
digitalität auch in frage stellen das
ist ganz klar
man kann sagen digitalität dies nur eine
besondere form von kultur
es ist vielleicht ein bisschen das
modische kultur im grunde genommen
hatten wir alles auch schon was jetzt
dann durch das internet zustande kann
und diese these möchte ich wie gesagt
problematisiert ich glaube tatsächlich
dass wir jetzt hier
gerade aber dieser moment mit einer ganz
neuen realität zu tun bekommen
in der bild entsteht und dass wir als
philosophen und philosophen neue
begriffe reden müssen die von mir
vorgeschlagen sind noch keineswegs
perfekt sind in keiner weise vollständig
ab jetzt soll also versuchen die
begriffe entwickeln die diese neue
realität für angemessen beschreiben und
eben über anderen sphären der existenz
klar abgrenzen lassen
damit einher gehen natürlich auch
gefahren
ich hatte gesagt der digitalität hat
auch eine ethische dimension jedes vor
allem deswegen weil gewisse dir nicht
vergessen werden denken sie an die
moralische kategorie de verzeihung
die zeit heilt alle wunden und sollte
wenn tatsächlich das internet in
digitalisierten nichts vergisst dann
wird es mit dem verzeiht vielleicht auch
ein bisschen schwieriger
also müssen wir uns selbst glaube ich
gedanken machen wie ändert sich unsere
moralischen und kulturellen koexistenz
weisen wenn die logik der zeit wie mir
scheint verändert denn alles was sie
vergessen weil ich gar nicht
möglich wird und die kategorie als raum
ist ehrlich gesagt werden hat sich auch
ganz legal in die wir ihnen in der
objektivität die wir zu den beliebten
existieren werden distanzen zum
verschwindend klein
wir können sofort die information
erhalten die wir wollen wir sind in
sekundenbruchteilen und die und die welt
herum und haben diese veränderung der
räumlichen logik wird sich
notwendigerweise demnächst oder
vielleicht jetzt schon auch im
moralischen dimensionen ausdrücken und
hier sind wir schon sehr gefordert diese
probleme damit auch einhergehen zu
reflektieren und mögliche lösung für
diese probleme auch vorzuschlagen
dann natürlich wollen wir sagen zum
schluss steht ist nichts nicht zu
verwechseln mit einem vorschnellen
optimismus mit einem blinden im technik
optimismus das soll häufig ein gelände
das an sagt diese pure datenflut
überfordert uns wir können gar nicht
mehr kritisch dass sich die weniger
wichtig unterscheiden
das ist sicherlich eine gefahr die
digitalisierung hier geht aber das ist
noch kein argument gegen die chancen und
überhaupt gegen die existenz einer
signatur
weil nämlich angesichts dieser
informationsflut natürlich bestimmte
strategie entwickelt werden müssen wir
werden diesen schier unüberschaubaren
fülle von informationen zu uns
orientieren können
aber hier gibt es schon erste schritte
zum beispiel suchmaschinen
suchalgorithmen und die zähle ich
bereits zur schwere der tritte
der digitalität also die frage wie wir
in dieser unüberschaubaren welt der
informations- und steinweg bank diese
frage ist selbst eine folge die damit
ihren und die lösung natürlich auch und
diese lösung werden
gänzlich andere art sein als zum
beispiel strategien
wenn man jetzt in dieser bibliothek die
informationen beschafft wirklich nicht
mehr zu bestimmten regal und wir geben
auch nicht einfach hier diese computer
werden wir also bin ich glaube dass
orientiere mit seiner digitalität eine
völlig andere struktur eine völlig
andere natur hat als die bisherigen
orientierungssuche in dieser welt die
ich jetzt die zwei seiten nennen wollte
das ist jetzt mein vorschlag ist also
ich glaube wir haben es mit einer neuen
realität formation dritten text vor
die identität möchte nur zur diskussion
weitergehen vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit